red to go forwards backwards is blue and
we have a new tenet fan theory for you
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the antagonist when
it comes to spoiler free videos
and this time we're breaking down a
theory that says sator was
actually working for the protagonist the
entire film before we get into it i just
want to shout out trust nobody for
sending me this through
and when i first started reading it i
was a bit unsure
however the further i got into the
entire thing the more it started to line
up i've added some things i've noticed
after reading it
and i think there's a lot of hints
towards this being the case
now the entire theory centers around the
idea that saito was unwittingly
recruited by the future protagonist to
collect
all nine pieces of the algorithm so that
his past self could steal them in the
finale
as we learned at the end of the movie
the plan the entire time was to let
saito collect the mcguffin
so that the tenet team could swipe it
from under his nose and they then could
separate it and guard it for the rest of
their lives
they would allow a detonation to go off
at stealth 12
so it would seem to the past version of
sator that he was always destined to win
and therefore events would play out the
same seido was actually someone who
thought that he was destined to beat
everybody
because of his knowledge of the future
and he used temporal pincers at several
points to make sure he always achieved
his goals
thus this detonation tricked his past
self into believing that the algorithm
was buried
and in his mind the character would
emerge victorious because fate
determined it
however it could be that he was just
being manipulated by the protagonist
from the future
and all that he was in the end was a
pawn in the chess game
now in the conversation with priya we
learn of a scientist
in the future that created the algorithm
we discover that after realizing its
power
she inverted it and decided to bury it
and send it to the past so that it could
never be used
what's strange though is that when saito
digs up the pieces
he discovers messages in the time
capsules along with gold bars
i have no idea why the scientist would
send these pieces back to the past to be
dug up by someone that would actually
assemble them
as it seems to juxtapose her main goal
which is to hide everything
thus someone clearly intervened and it
could be that the protagonist
potentially
intercepted these and placed the
instructions inside that would lead to
sator finding the rest so that it could
be assembled
now the pieces of the algorithm are
buried at some of the most highly
guarded places in the world
so it seems unlikely that one scientist
could have placed them all there
especially when we consider the time it
would have taken
thus it seems more likely that the
protagonists took the pieces
and placed them with instructions so
that sato would act the way he did in
the past
the protagonist is obviously operating
from the future
and he wants things to go exactly as
planned
so it's unlikely he would leave anything
to chance nolan gives us strong hints
towards this and who saito's orders are
coming from
as the protagonist is actually present
during the two times in the film
that we see him getting them now the
first point is when the villain is on
the yacht reminiscing about his past
and though the protagonist wasn't
present at stahls 12.
this scene could be sato telling his
past self so that his feature version
knows to leave a capsule at the location
the second time we see him receiving his
orders is later that evening
i do think this is a hint from nolan as
there are no other scenes with sator
receiving orders
sator at one point mocks the protagonist
for following the tenet organization
purely on blind faith because he trusts
them without actually knowing anything
about it
or the people within however in many
respects
satoru is too operating on blind faith
as he tells the protagonists that the
future wants to wipe out the past
because their oceans rose and their
rivers run dry
there is no way for the character to
verify this and he's merely
operating on the word of the future the
protagonist even says the line
knowledge divided my friend ignorance is
our ammunition
which is pretty much the mantra of tenet
keeping the truth from people allows
them to follow orders without asking
questions and this is a principle that's
laced in military preparation
this is why priya's story doesn't line
up and the protagonist clearly doesn't
mind using her either
as he's happy to kill her in the finale
despite being inverted and sent back in
time
the pieces of the algorithm that we see
never display any inverted properties
they don't fly up into people's hands
like the bullet and they all seem to
contradict what we're told
now the theory goes on to wonder why the
us military might be so incompetent as
to lose their peace to sator
who in comparison is just a mere thug it
could in fact be that all nine pieces
are russian
and that it's merely some type of secret
atomic weapon developed by the soviets
when discussing why sator was chosen
priya says because he was in the right
place at the right time
namely the soviet union which was the
most insecure moment in the history of
nuclear weapons
thus the protagonist is actually waging
a cold war in the future against them
and is simply using sator as a puppet in
the past to make sure the u.s
win now one of the most shocking points
in the theory asks why the future
protagonist
still sent neil to his death it could be
that he viewed him as an expendable
soldier and that because he didn't stick
to his orders that the protagonist had
him taken down
ives tells the red team that the
splinter team's task is need to know
and you don't and then tells the
protagonist that the splinter team
is just ives in himself he even says no
one who knows the contents of that
capsule
can leave the field that's why neil was
killed
because he saw the contents of the
capsule when he pulled ives and the
protagonist
out neil was on the blue team he was not
supposed to assist the splinter team
and therefore he disobeyed his orders we
know neil is not supposed to be there
because commander wheeler tells the blue
team
if you're not at the lz at zero you are
not leaving
the camera even focuses on neil during
this as if nolan is hinting at neil's
disobedience and death
i've selected only the protagonist and
himself for the splinter team
because that's what the future
protagonist told him to do
ives has no reason to select him to be
on such an important team
unless he was informed by the future
version of the character
that he was integral to the mission neil
even tells us that this entire operation
is orchestrated by the protagonists from
the future so we know that everything
carried out by it is put in place by him
now if this theory is true then that
means neil will not have been killed by
accident as when sato tells volkov to
shoot the protagonist in the head
saito is merely following the future
protagonist's orders
at this exact moment neil was shot in
the head
and it seems too big of a coincidence to
not have been meant to happen there and
then
ives was still knocked out at this point
so he wouldn't know exactly when the
shot that killed neil happened
and therefore the protagonist is the
only living person at this event that
had the information
nolan even hints that it's the
protagonist who has neil killed
by one of the scenes early on in the
movie i'll set you up as a go-between
but remember to you
it's all about plutonium when we're done
they'll kill you
why don't you have to do that anyway i'd
rather be my decision
so would i well when we're done they'll
kill you
why don't you have to do that anyway i'd
rather be my decision
so would i so this is hinting to the
audience that it was the protagonist's
decision to kill neil
and he decided that from the future
however the way that we see it is that
sato asks volkov to shoot the
protagonist in the head
but as we know neil was standing in
front of him in order to take the bullet
neil saves the protagonist's life at the
opera tries to warn him and knives of
the booby trap in the tunnel
saves them from the explosion by lifting
them from the hippocenter
and unlocks the gate to volkov and the
area it's neil who saves the day
and yet he's killed for it now the
theory takes a very interesting turn and
states that neil is the characteristic
gullible and expendable soldier even
though he knows he's going to die in the
end
he's happy following orders because he's
resigned himself to the fact that he
doesn't have free will
it's very well summed up by lines from
the character dylan and the predator
movie at the half hour mark
an expendable asset and i used you to
get the job done
got it neil was used to get the job done
and then he was taken care of dylan even
lies to duchy about the true nature of
the mission
as dutch says
it's all [ __ ] so you cooked up a
story and dropped the six of us in a
meat grinder
so in the end the protagonist from the
future an almost godlike character
was simply using everyone as a pawn to
make sure the events
happened the way they were supposed to
this happened with not only sator
but also neil who he knew he was sending
to his death
he viewed everyone as expendable
including brie and knew that their
sacrifices would have to be made in
order to save the world
it's quite a chilling theory but i think
it adds a whole other layer to the movie
and next time you watch the film try to
bear this in mind as i definitely think
it holds up
what i love about tennis is that it
completely switches your perspective
and it's a film that changes every time
you watch it so hopefully
this is giving you another reason to
check it out anyway
thank you for watching the video and
again huge shout outs to trust nobody
now don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theory
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown in
which we answer some of the
biggest questions surrounding the movie
and i think you really enjoy
as we kind of clear a lot of things up
anyway with that out of the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been ball i'll see you next time
take care peace